social distancing supposed to me to
support linchpins all liability that's
the quandary Boris Johnson is wrestling
with this morning as Dominic Cummings
faces new allegations that as well as
travelling 260 miles to Durham to self
isolate with his family close to his
parents he also took two day trips
firstly breaking his quarantine to visit
a picturesque town 30 miles away and
secondly even after returning to number
ten then making another trip up to the
northeast in response number 10 say
yesterday the mirror and The Guardian
wrote inaccurate stories about mr.
Cummings today they are writing more
inaccurate stories including claims that
mr. Cummings returned to Durham after
returning to work in Downing Street on
the 14th of April we will not waste our
time answering a stream of false
allegations about mr. Cummings from
campaigning newspapers Downing Street do
not explain what those inaccuracies are
yes
today the government's defense was
focused on the welfare of Dominic
Cummings his son and his
responsibilities as a father with Boris
Johnson giving his full support and
cabinet ministers coming to his aid I
understand what you're saying I get what
you're saying
you know mr. Cummings is a you know in
the public eye but the reality of the
matter is of the four-year-old child's
welfare I think is the important thing
but opposition parties are now piling on
the pressure with labor and the SMP
calling for a civil service
investigation the most senior official
in the land and government effectively
advising the Prime Minister and we need
to get to the bottom of what's going on
and on the basis of what we know I
cannot see that his position
is tenable in any way shape or form at
all I think he simply has to go and
Boris Johnson has to make himself
available to answer the questions that
journalist wants to poop
tomorrow Boris Johnson will chair
cabinet and in the coming days he's
expected to set out more details of how
his government will lift the lockdown
but it will still require all of us to
be disciplined and follow the rules that
may now be far more difficult Dominick
Cummings has faced his own political
mortality before surely now he's running
out of lives
Joe Pike Sky News Westminster